it's another day and tragically it's
another mass shooting at least
10 people have been killed in colorado
in a supermarket shooting
uh as often as the case with these
incidents the news
the details are still coming in the
associated press has a good summary so
far
and they write that a shooting at a
colorado supermarket yesterday
killed 10 people including one police
officer who was the first to respond to
the scene
the suspect has been taken alive police
have not yet revealed the suspect's
name although we know uh it is a a male
individual not too many other details
have yet been released and investigators
are sorting
through evidence this happened at the
king supers
store in boulder colorado this is
um boulder's about 25 miles uh i think
it's about 40-ish minutes
from denver this was the seventh
mass killing in the united states this
year we just had a shooting on march
16th
which of course left eight people dead
at
some massage businesses in the atlanta
area
in the state of georgia and
you know i i don't want to make any
jokes about this this this is
insane what is going on but one of the
things
that was sort of different during the
pandemic was that the mass shootings
slowed down and i saw someone saying
you can tell we're coming out of the
pandemic because the mass shootings are
increasing
and it's it's it's not even a joke i
mean it's it's
it's sad that that's the reality the
officer who died is
51 year old eric talley who had been
with the boulder police for about
11 years he went to the store
when a call for shots fired and someone
carrying a rifle
came in and um he
was killed in the line of duty the other
nine victims
identities as of a few hours ago when i
prepared for this story had not yet been
released but my
instinct is that some of those uh names
and identities will probably
um start to be made public soon the
situation as we understand it
is that um police uh
arrived and uh found some
individuals uh who were
it was a chaotic scene at one point we
know officers
escorted a man without a shirt and blood
running from his leg out of the store in
handcuffs
although they haven't yet even confirmed
that that's the suspect
officials have also not said whether the
suspect
is the individual that was taken to a
particular hospital
in boulder or not the hospital is not
giving out any information
it's still all very early and
of course every time that we have an
incident like this you see
all of the sort of normal and
predictable reactions from different
people
those uh on the right whose priority is
to defend
the ability and right and and legality
of having guns and having whatever guns
people want in whatever situations even
arguing that
more people armed that this incident
could have actually
prevented it from being as bad you also
have people who
understandably say this this is yet uh
you know another rifle and for all the
talk about handguns being the vast
majority of individual homicide
incidents where there are
one or two victims rifles continue to
play a prevalent and significant role
in the mass shootings and people who go
to that i mean
for me nothing really changes because of
yet another tragic incident we sort of
know
what the low-hanging fruit is around gun
safety and then we know
sort of the bigger hills to climb you
will also get people who
anytime there's a shooting and people
want to talk about gun laws will say
you know a tragedy is not the time to
politicize
uh gun control and that's like a trash
comment that comment
deserves to be thrown in in the
incinerator
and incinerated and done away with
completely
if you ever want to talk about gun
safety in close time proximity to an
acute event
you're told oh it's too soon and then if
you
wait you're told it's not really an
issue it's been a while since we had the
last mass shooting
they never want to talk about it and i
think it's important not to be dissuaded
uh not to be dissuaded by that we also
of course saw
i'm not even going to get into it
because it would it would be the entire
show but i think many of you won't be
surprised to know
that right-wing networks including fox
news um during
like all night last night when every
other network was covering this
uh they were covering you know what's
going on why did joe biden
trip going up the stairs that was a big
part of hannity
one fox show did like a brief mention of
the shooting but the only context in
which they mentioned it was
how a colorado college basketball team
found out about the shooting shortly
before their game and they were really
affected
by the shooting during the game it's
like the trash coverage that we would
expect
and that's no surprise to anybody by
tomorrow we may know more about this as
we start to learn more about
possibly motive or other circumstances
uh we will talk about it but as usual
it doesn't have to be a shooting
motivated by
anything in particular to reinforce the
need
to be dramatically uh uh changing the
legal infrastructure around gun
ownership and again
universal background checks i'm not
saying that that's what's relevant here
but most of the country wants it and
much like with covet relief it doesn't
matter
republican elected officials just won't
hear anything of any any of it
uh continues to be a tragedy that the
world looks at us and says what
how why why why not do something
what is going on in the united states it
is a sickness that
disproportionately affects this country
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook called takeover how
a conservative student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook
from noah feldman it just came out and
feldman actually narrates the audiobook
himself noah feldman of course
is a harvard law professor and
constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent
role in trump's impeachment number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
are current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just
4.99 and you can get it at
davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy audiobooks